en el vídeo pasado encontramos la
esperanza la varianza y la desviación
estándar de la distribución bernouilli
con números específicos 40 y 60 lo que
voy a hacer en este vídeo es encontrar
la esperanza y la varianza de una
variable bernouilli cuando no tenemos
estos números ok
cuando lo único que tenemos es que la
probabilidad de éxito es p y la
probabilidad de fracaso es 1 - p ok
entonces bueno
a ver vamos a dibujar la función de
distribución de probabilidades entonces
la probabilidad de éxito que vamos ahora
a asociar con el 1 bueno definirlo con
el 1 ya tiene una probabilidad p
y la probabilidad de fracaso que ahora
va a ser el cero
1 - p lo que sea que eso sea ahora si
sumamos esos 2 lo que nos da es uno que
es el 100% y eso es exactamente lo que
tiene que pasar porque cualquier
experimento tiene que ser un éxito
y algo que no sea un éxito lo cual es un
fracaso ok
bien entonces si hay 40 por ciento de
probabilidad de tener un éxito tiene que
haber 60 por ciento de probabilidad de
que haya un fracaso
esta es la definición más general de una
variable
berlín de la distribución berlín
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es calcular
la esperanza de esta variable que
también se llama media y la varianza
también lo cual es la esperanza de la
distancia de la variable a su media
entonces a ver empecemos con la
esperanza cual es la esperanza cuál es
la media
bueno la esperanza es la suma de los
valores que puede tomar por la
probabilidad que tome cada uno de esos
valores entonces tenemos una
probabilidad de 1 p de obtener un
fracaso
ahora estamos llamándole 0 al fracaso
entonces tenemos 1 - p x 0
más la probabilidad de obtener un 1 que
espe el 1 es el éxito por la variable
que es 1 es muy fácil de calcular no o
sea cualquier cosa por cero es cero y
cualquier post cosa por uno es esa misma
cosa entonces en total nuestra media es
simplemente p nuestra media nuestra
esperanza
espe y pues estar por acá y sabemos que
nuestra variable no puede tomar ese
valor pero pues sigue siendo nuestra
esperanza
entonces ahora vamos con la varianza y
la varianza es la esperanza de la
distancia de la variable de la historia
a la media y después eso todo eso al
cuadrado pero pues tenemos que
desarrollar la suma bueno tenemos que
desarrollar la esperanza entonces la
probabilidad de obtener un 0 es 1 - p y
luego tenemos que multiplicar por la
distancia del 0 a la media al cuadrado
no entonces aquí es cero
- que es el valor que está tomando la
variable
0 - nuestra media que es p
a ver déjame el cambio del color naranja
quedará bien yo creo que no mejor le
ponemos un blanco entonces pero no es
menos nuestra media que esté
más la probabilidad de obtener un 1 lo
cual es p por la distancia de 1 a la
media
oigan espérense aquí se nos olvidó lo
tenemos que elevar al cuadrado porque
son las distancias al cuadrado a ver
entonces cuál es la distancia de nuestra
variable cuando toma el valor 1 a la
media pues es 1 - p y luego lo tenemos
que elevar al cuadrado también no
entonces lo elevamos al cuadrado esta es
la varianza ok entonces bueno a ver
vamos a desarrollarla
1 - p x tenemos 0 - p al cuadrado lo
cual es menos p al cuadrado pero eso es
simplemente p cuadrada más
ok te por 1p al cuadrado desarrollamos
lo que lo que nos queda es 1 al cuadrado
que es 1
- 2 de este por este baja
lo cual son menos 2 p2p y luego más
menos p al cuadrado
es nada más p cuadrada otra vez
entonces vamos a multiplicar estos
términos para que quede en la forma más
simple
este término de aquí es p cuadrada - p
cúbica y luego este otro término es p
pero por 1 - 2 pp que es menos 2p
cuadrado y luego p por p cuadrada que
este al cubo
ahora podemos simplificar esto pedal a 3
se cancela con menos para 3 y luego hay
otros dos que se cancelan por ahí
entonces al final lo que nos queda es
esta p baja y después p cuadrada menos 2
p cuadrada lo cual nos queda simplemente
- p cuadrada
y le podemos factorizar una p
entonces nos queda p x / p que es 1 - p
cuadrada entre p que nos queda nada más
p lo cual es una expresión muy sencilla
bonita y elegante entonces bueno no está
varianza es por 1 - p si queremos sacar
la desviación estándar lo único que
tenemos que hacer es sacar la raíz a la
varianza lo cual es igual a la raíz de p
por 1 - p y podemos verificar que lo que
hicimos aquí es congruente con lo que
hicimos en el vídeo pasado en el ejemplo
nuestra esperanza es p que es
exactamente la probabilidad de obtener
un éxito que es punto 6 y sabemos que
nuestra varianza es exactamente p por 1
- p que es la probabilidad de éxito por
la probabilidad de fracaso en este caso
eran punto 4 la probabilidad de fracaso
y punto 6 la probabilidad de éxito que
si las multiplicamos nos quedan punto 24
y luego si le sacamos raíz pues nos
queda la desviación estándar igual
que en el vídeo pasado espero que lo
encuentres útil nosotros lo vamos a usar
muchísimo para hacer inferencia
estadística